Can you introduce yourself to the audience
of the Nexus Institute?
You wrote this great book, the first of a
series of four, on Lincoln.
What are you - a journalist, a writer, a political
man?
Well, I think the best way to describe myself
is through the experience that I brought to
bear in writing this book.
I grew up in Chicago, Illinois.
Illinois is Lincoln's state.
It's in the middle of the United States, and
I have that perspective, that vantage point,
that I can bring to American society, culture
and politics.
I became a journalist and have been a journalist
for many years.
I worked for such publications as the New
Republic, the Washington Post
and the New Yorker.
I've written many books about American politics,
and I served with president Clinton in the
White House.
I've been active in campaigns and elections,
as a Democrat, and I'm a historian.
Why is it that you got so involved in American
politics?
At the age of 12, I became entranced with
a presidential political campaign.
That campaign was in 1960, and the candidate
was John F. Kennedy.
When I grew up in Chicago there was a political
organization, a Democratic party organization.
Every part of the city had what was called
a 'precinct captain', who was a member of
the Democratic Party.
That precinct captain recruited me as a boy,
to help him after school to get people to
vote.
I would go around and speak to my neighbours
on election day, and say you would vote.
And my reward was that my precinct captain
took me to the rally to see John F. Kennedy,
and that made an enormous impression on me.
Shortly after that I was taken to Springfield,
Illinois, which is where Lincoln was from.
Springfield has many of the sites that Lincoln
was involved in: the State Capitol, his law
office, the little town where he had lived
outside of Springfield as a young man.
Shortly after that Martin Luther King came
to my city, and I saw Dr. King.
And so I saw, even in the North, not the South,
the Civil Rights movement and its greatest
leader.
All of these things combined to impress upon
me and awaken in me an interest in
American politics.